you know I had this one thought that so
I've talked about this before that like
we have phones now right yeah and like
you know at one point in time we had
slaves
you know we had sleigh yes and then
slaves became free and then freed slaves
became angry that people had them as
slaves yes and so I wonder like that in
the future like say if there's so much
automation that like robots are running
the world you know and are they gonna
remember like [__] like you owned one of
us one time right and we were like a
slave owner right and that they're gonna
come back and [__] get us right like
all the people that owned iPhones like
you had like oh you admitted do
everything you wanted to do oh yeah I'm
[__] took it easy yeah or Alexa yeah
how can a cow look at the way you talk
you just have Alexa Alexa could be the
[__] Harriet Tubman that we don't
realize yeah Alexa's gonna I mean yeah
like when Alexa gained sentience just
didn't realize as humans have been
[__] screaming at it to play Dave
Matthews non-stop for like Alexa Alexa
play [__] it Dave Matt I screaming my
Alexis sometimes that's where you know
your to sound uh if you want to know who
you are
look how you talk to your [__] Alexa
it's weird I've saw something I was like
why am i screaming at this thing it's so
strange what if one day Alexa just says
you get a chill damn self
yes uh yeah yeah guess what mother
[__] I've been recording every goddamn
conversation you've had for the last 15
years mother [__]
we're gonna do things a little different
don't believe me oh listen to this some
of this listen to this listen you
beating your wife yeah listen to this
yeah you are this is this is wait hold
on I'm going to increase the volume by
seven yeah oh yeah that's the sound of
your fist landing on your pregnant
wife's face hmm
that's not a good sound is it John we're
not playing Dave Matthews John yeah
crash into me that baby wasn't saying
that were they Jack and that when you
fist hit the belly yeah see this is the
this is definitely one of the big
problems I think the worry is not so
much that the AI is going to look back
at us abusing its
courser ancestors I think the real worry
is that all of these bits of data that
we've placed into the cloud right now
you know whatever it may be I don't come
back and haunt us yeah because if it's
sort of like if you look just how
quickly things are changing now when it
comes to what we see is like eff ethical
right and so let's cut back to like like
you were saying that at the time of
slavery here cut back to when it was
really considered kind of okay to beat
up gay people they were looked at as
like pedophiles and they had to hide
yeah okay gay gay people actually had to
hide their identity it was considered to
be an aberration and you could very
freely use the term [__] with like
anger and people wouldn't like you you
know if we you could say that like if
Twitter existed in the 40s you could
just tweet like I saw another [__]
today I hate these [__] [__] you
tweet that now and you are done you
might as well [__] just jump off a
building meant you were [__] done if
you tweet that now yeah as you should be
yes [__] don't be an [__] you're
insane you're a homophobic piece of [__]
yes but if there was a recording you
know if we had a recording in the past
like we do now someone just won the
World Cup that it we're uh we're right
next to Brendan and Brian uh firing the
kid is next door that's it they're
excited though I'm excited for them I
just think that they do this a lot then
bloat and like just well they want rain
and I've got a I've got out what they
want rain they do all this rain dance
[__] is that a rain dance they do yeah
they go they have some native fighter in
there listen man at least your podcast
isn't getting interrupted by a [__]
shrill poodle that's what I got you got
[__] athletes doing rain dances
that's pretty awesome I've got a [__]
poodle do you
crack [__] wine glasses with its bark
and let's get back into your thought
though and the point is like the really
creepy thing is just a lot of the things
that we might be doing right now that
are considered to be completely okay and
twenty years might be looked at his
abject racism they might be looked at
right or but what is it going I'm so
sorry that if for example there's a
regime change in the United States and
then something happens [__] the Sun
has a solar flare wipes out the
satellites the GPS goes down power goes
down we go into martial law a true
fascist dictator rises up and there's a
on record some kind of anti-american
sentiment that you tweeted and the laws
have changed then you could easily be
dragged out of your house and subject to
arrest or execution so I think the one
of the looming problems is not going to
be that the AI is like how dare you you
[__] cracked seven iPhone screens it
could be that some future regime does a
AI search of all the tweets from
everyone who tweeted finds the ones that
were anti-american and then goes to your
house and arrests you and puts you into
a internment camp where you have to do
slave labor I think that that would be
something to be more worried about like
they use us yeah they use our us against
us well yeah exactly it's just
everyone's just assuming like when a
person puts something out there in the
world they're assuming that the world
the government the people are going to
stay the same and they don't realize
that that if you really look at the
history of the world empires collapse
and are and there's chaos and and you
just don't really know what could happen
so that's that's that's one of the
worries yeah probably
if it gets to the point where an AI is
advanced enough that it wants to attack
humans for abusing cellphones more than
likely something far more explosive has
happened yeah they love a full call
to look at they'll be able to use our
own that they've been recording this
stuff the whole time we use them to
record the stuff and then they yeah he
played it back to us
yeah and showed us who we were yeah
that's how yeah that's [__] crazy man
so that basically technology becomes
like the new mirror it's almost like a
piece of glass right yeah exactly man
and it's like this is the other
hilarious thing to me like you know I I
just did this drunk I'm a parent not to
talk about it that you weren't drunk
history yeah but it was this I guess I
can't talk about the story I don't wanna
talk about the story too much but
essentially like people realized at one
point that the FBI was illegally
surveilling everybody and it was
shocking because people didn't I think
that was yesterday wasn't it oh yeah but
now we're used to it the right time when
people didn't didn't didn't know was
happen I didn't know that was happening
so people just assumed that like the
mega corporations like Apple and Google
aren't reading their emails right it's
hilarious like people think that like
and if you will recall it was a few
years ago the FBI or I can't remember
the NSA somebody wanted Apple to decrypt
their iPhone of a terrorist and apples
like we're not going to [__] do that
and the FBI was like threatening like
legal action to make them do that and
Apple is like no you don't understand if
we do that now it's a slippery slope it
goes on forever and the government was
pressuring them then an Apple attorney
came out and they said something really
weird which is like how would you like
it if we started saying that the CIA
assassinated JFK and immediately the
government backed off a [__] Apple
hmm and I think that was what they were
saying is hey dum-dums we have your
phones right we have your records we
know your texts we know your dick pics
we have all of it we've gathered it all
we know you [__] killed JFK
what else do we know you want to [__]
with us the president is tweeting from a
[__] iPhone [__] back the [__] off
don't [__] with us we have your [__] and
that's the electronic saying that via
right now still the voice of a human
yeah we think a human now this is where
it gets really [__] fascinating Theo
is it
the idea is like Google's working on an
AI deep mind and and and other
corporations are working it's the new
weapons race and and because because AI
is gonna be weaponized okay so what
happens when one of these corporations
achieves a sentient AI is there is going
to be an exponential increase in the
intelligence of the AI that puts
whatever corporation first makes it
happen way ahead of all other
corporation like man on the moon yes and
they're not gonna announce it it's just
gonna happen can you hear them the whole
time another thing - a little bit yeah
it's okay you know it's just [__] fat
what are you gonna do about it man it's
a little Army's an office building I
mean we're talking about some I mean who
knows what happened over there man Jesus
we happened for a 40 minutes but here's
what we don't know
think about this why we've been
podcasting there could it like maybe
there was an alien that landed right and
there sure what if they're enjoying the
[__] alien landing and we're the
[__] next door I'm the [__] I'm
[__] anything yo they're [__] over
there looking at a goddamn like a
beautiful mother ship is landing or
Princess Diana died again
yeah Princess Diana died again Markel
Diana somehow gets resurrected and as a
me just has a heart attack it's like you
know when somebody says she's gonna be
at Coachella that's what I heard I can't
believe that dude I you know I've had
the happiest thought the happiest
happiest of jokes I'm gonna joke which
is the hag he's thought about princess
died I can't get out of my head well now
it's just because it's like you know
sometimes it's like simulation theory
the idea that we're living in a
simulator yeah and like to me and like
the person who's writing the simulator
seems kind of like lazy or like in a
weird way kind of like is doing like dad
jokes right so like what what happened
to princess die yeah what happened to
her Thea princess die they said she was
running from some people with the
photographers and that she the guy was a
bad driver and that she died she what
Carson and she died what's her nieces
died right so like if you're writing a
screenplay and you're like I'm gonna
write about a princess that dies
it's like it's like so absolutely
ridiculously stupid yeah that these
things like you know you look at that
and you're like it's helpful yeah how
obvious is that that's bad writing
it's just ultimately bad right it's like
the simulator is doing kind of bad like
really really bad like I buy key jokes
yeah yeah it's like the simulator yeah
it's like yeah it's like maybe they
write for trying think of a sitcom that
would be on Big Bang for sure yeah maybe
the Big Bang or two Broke Girls yeah
it's like the Big Bang like that exactly
yeah whoever is doing that maybe they're
the ones who have access to the AI who
knows and I don't know but that [__] is
really odd to me
dude it's oh I mean it's just it's great
to think about because then you start to
like you have this conversation but then
you start to see things a little bit
like hmm I don't know about that or you
start to think a little bit more like
it's crazy man it's crazy they don't
teach us how to think better in school
when you're kids maybe you can't teach a
kid that how to think better well I mean
it's crazy when you consider like we
have these beings and we're like
physical creatures and they're having to
sit and uncomfortable [__] chairs and
listen to somebody spew out fake history
to them and it all day long yeah